للمرة الثامنة على مدار
الأسبوعين الماضيين، شهدنا قيام الولايات المتحدة
بتنفيذ ضربات في اليمن تستهدف
أصول الحوثيين التي تم استخدامها
لضرب وشن هجمات ضد
سفن الشحن التجارية في البحر الأحمر
وخليج عدن، وهما من أكبر السفن في العالم.
الممرات المائية الأكثر أهمية هذه المرة رأينا مرة أخرى
المملكة المتحدة تشارك في هذه الضربات
مع تحالف دولي
يتكون من كندا وهولندا
والبحرين وأستراليا لدعم
العملية. لم تستخدم الولايات المتحدة فقط طائرات مقاتلة من طراز F-18
تم إطلاقها من دوايت
دي أيزنهاور الأمريكي، بل استخدمت أيضًا طائرات  الحاملة
الموجودة في المنطقة ولكن أيضًا
السفن السطحية والغواصة لإطلاق
صواريخ توماهوك كروز، تقول المملكة المتحدة
في الوقت نفسه إنها تستخدم طائرات مقاتلة من طراز تايفون
كجزء من الضربة التي نفذتها الولايات المتحدة
على ثمانية
مواقع منفصلة باستخدام حوالي 25 إلى 30
ذخيرة موجهة بدقة وفقًا  لمسؤول
عسكري كبير أطلع
الصحفيين بعد الضربة على أن
الضربات كانت ناجحة وحققت
التأثير المطلوب وفقًا لذلك
المسؤول وكذلك مسؤول دفاع كبير
كان جزءًا من ذلك
الإحاطة الآن وأشاروا إلى أن
الولايات المتحدة كانت ستذهب على وجه التحديد  بعد
أنواع الأسلحة والقدرات التي
استخدمها الحوثيون والوكلاء المدعومين من إيران في اليمن لمهاجمة
الشحن الدولي، مما يعني أنهم لا يحاولون
توسيع الهدف المحدد على أنواع
الأسلحة التي حاولوا تدميرها على
مدار الماضي.  بعد مرور أسبوعين،
يقولون إنهم نجحوا
في استهداف هذه الأسلحة التي تشمل
طائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ بالإضافة إلى
موقع تخزين تحت الأرض لهذه
القدرات لأول مرة، لكن ذلك أدى إلى
تدهور قدرات الحوثيين التي تعتقد الولايات المتحدة
أنها تلاحق وتهدد
الشحن التجاري.
يظل التهديد مطروحًا على الطاولة في هذه المرحلة إذا
استمرت هجمات العوي ضد
الشحن الدولي، فهل ستستمر
العمليات الأمريكية هنا، وقد رأينا الآن مرة أخرى
المملكة المتحدة تنضم إلى هذا، كما أصدرت
نفس التحذير بأنه ما لم يتم شن
هجمات على ممرات الشحن الدولية
توقفوا إذن، لن توقف ضربات LED الأمريكية والبريطانية على
الأصول الصينية السؤال إلى أين
سيذهب هذا من هنا، سيتوقع المسؤولون الذين
أطلعوا المراسلين نوعاً ما
في أي اتجاه سيذهب هذا الأمر فقط ليقولوا
إن الولايات المتحدة ستستمر في العمل كما
ترى.  الحاجة إلى أورين ليبرمان سي إن إن في
البنتاغون